[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que nos
lleva a panamá específicamente a la zona
un pequeño territorio estadounidense de
1400 kilómetros cuadrados que bordeó el
canal interoceánico dividiendo al país
centroamericano en dos durante casi un
siglo se necesitaron más de 30 años para
construir el canal entre el siglo 19 y
el siglo 20
esta estructura conecta a los océanos
atlántico y pacífico cortando la franja
de tierra más estrecha de américa
central en panamá o eeuu el que terminó
su construcción y las orillas se
convirtieron en una colonia llamada la
zona establecida en 1903 en el pico de
su ocupación durante los años 50 había
alrededor de 100 mil ciudadanos
estadounidenses aislados del resto del
país se crearon un pequeño eeuu canchas
de béisbol y de fútbol americano tiendas
con productos importados casas al estilo
colonial una burbuja de riqueza de la
cual los panameños estaban excluidos la
mayoría de los estadounidenses
decidieron irse de la zona pero algunas
de sus costumbres se quedaron regresamos
para ver cómo los panameños recuerdan
esta amar
bateadores lanzadores comerciales en
inglés es un entrenamiento en un estadio
de chicago o nueva york no estamos en
panamá mientras en américa latina' el
fútbol domina la escena deportiva los
panameños solo piensan en el béisbol
si podemos llenarlo de orgullo de que el
mejor relevista de todos los tiempos de
panamá mariano ribera uno de los mejores
bateadores de todos los tiempos es rod
carew de panamá en realidad estas
superestrellas de las grandes ligas no
se formaron en panamá sino en la zona
una franja de tierra de 16 kilómetros de
largo que bordeaba el canal y que es
dividió a panamá en dos durante casi un
siglo un territorio estadounidense esta
extraña frontera común influenció
profundamente la cultura panameña de
cinco ligas alrededor de 50 ligas en un
par de años porque la verdad
jugar contra los brindo era lo máximo
había esa rivalidad entre panameños y
norteamericanos saná deportivamente
la zona parecía un pueblo tranquilo y
próspero del sur de eeuu
jon mercier aquí a la derecha llegó a
los 17 años era como un pequeño país
artificial construido y dirigido por
ingenieros
hijo de un militar trabajó para la
compañía del canal toda su vida era un
paraíso un paraíso socialista es
interesante porque la mayoría de las
personas que vivieron aquí son muy
conservadoras y anti socialistas y sin
embargo crecieron en este lugar donde
todas las casas serán construidas por el
gobierno donde todo el mundo era
funcionario público y donde todos
teníamos seguridad social
entonces nos sobraba mucho dinero para
hacer trabajos públicos cuidar el jardín
pintar las casas cambiar los bombillos
aquí todo estaba hecho para las personas
yo ni su amigo enrique sánchez eran
ambos son eros o habitantes de la zona
pero enrique nació en un lugar de la
zona reservado para los trabajadores
panameños a menudo afroamericanos la
segregación seguía siendo la norma hay
que entender que aquí estamos en la
parte estadounidense de la zona del
canal
y a todos esos niños panameños que
vivían a unas cuadras de aquí en
chorrillos santa anna
ellos siempre decían que cuando llegaba
acá los cargaban no podían jugar en el
área hoy en día la mayor parte de estos
edificios están ocupados por panameños
que viven entre los vestigios del pasado
de la zona del canal producía su propia
leche hacia sus propios helados se
vendían aquí
este es el cine pasaban películas que
antes habían sido verificadas y
aprobadas por la instancia de revisión
de la zona
fue en esta casa donde john y su primera
esposa criaron a su hija
a este árbol de mango antes no estaba
aquí después de la restitución del canal
de panamá
yo decidió quedarse en el país vivía en
muchos lugares antes de llegar a panama
pero el día que me bajé del avión y
llegué aquí pensé wow el verano eterno
las playas muchachas muy simpáticas con
un bronceado natural dios quiere que
este muchacho blanco se instale aquí
para siempre pero la mayor parte de sus
compatriotas se fueron hace mucho tiempo
los que nacieron aquí consideraban la
zona como si fuera su país y lo vieron
derrumbarse ahora panamá les hace falta
pero eso que amaban ya no existe cuando
era niño enrique y sus ocho hermanos y
hermanas vivieron otra realidad de la
zona
pedro meyer es un poblado
que era la zona del canal
pero es un favor a donde no vivían los
rectores sino para niños en mi época era
mayormente panameños que se bien de la
gente
pero yo viví en esta casa a partir de
los 10 años se puede ver la casa
en un chalet y como éramos la familia
grande en una casa de cuatro de cámara
enrique es nieto de trabajadores
jamaiquinos traídos aquí para construir
el canal en condiciones escalofriantes
la obra en esta selva inhóspita dejó al
menos 24 mil muertos su padre trabajaba
en la compañía del canal durante la
época de la zona y hoy en día
enrique es miembro del consejo de
dirección del canal un ascenso simbólico
de un país que se liberó del yugo
extranjero del niño yo no tuve nada que
ver con los primos
pero excepto la enfermera era una mujer
muy amable y era la única persona blanca
estadounidense con quien yo me relacione
de mí
a pesar de ese aislamiento enrique
recibió la excelente educación ofrecida
en la zona eso le permitió obtener
diplomas en grandes universidades en
eeuu y volverse ingeniero políticamente
bueno si el principio era cualquier cosa
sobre todo cuando uno lo recuerda hoy en
día
pero en esa época y en esas
circunstancias era un poco la norma
aunque duró mucho más tiempo de lo que
debía
[Música]
la calera
de siempre o la tierra
[Música]
miroslava nació a unos kilómetros de la
zona hoy con su grupo afrodisíaco canta
la diversidad y la soberanía de vuelta a
su país una riqueza y un orgullo después
de siglos de dominación primero por los
españoles luego por los franceses y
finalmente por los estadounidenses y esa
relación
que era más que todo racial y económica
se desarrolla pues a lo largo de varios
siglos al final esto tiene unos efectos
generacionales y podemos explicar lo que
los barrios más pobres y más
desesperados en la ciudad son barrios
afrodescendientes y barrios de pueblos
de hijos y descendientes de originario
esto no es ninguna sorpresa en el
pequeño puerto de pesca que bordea el
canal están los buques portacontenedores
de la opulencia y el mundo de los
marginados en 2016
panamá fue clasificado por el banco
mundial en el sexto puesto de los países
con mayores desigualdades económicas lo
que pasa de las redes y se pérdida para
los dueños de la embarcación
yo he perdido muchas redes así muchos
barcos me han daño la red y a quienes
pagar eso nadie lo bueno del canal bueno
gracias a dios nos trae no trae tampoco
otra vez turistas y no ayuda los
turistas bien me salen la pesca el canal
es la columna vertebral de panamá pero
no sólo desde el punto de vista
económico para miroslava es también un
pilar histórico y social y yo siempre
digo que el abuelo del canal es el
esclavo africano porque eran ellos lo
que al principio transportaban en sus
espaldas toda la riqueza que los
españoles empezaban a mover a través de
panamá porque los esclavos cruzaban el
istmo de panamá a través de la selva
construyendo los el camino real y el
camino de cruces para mover estas
riquezas robadas de américa hacia asia
europa en su tranquila residencia sobre
la bahía
jon vuelve a abrir por primera vez los
archivos de su juventud
vamos a ver que hay aquí dentro ahí
la pasión de jong era pasar el tiempo en
la selva no
certificado de entrenamiento de
sobrevivencia básica en la selva y
familiarización étnica otorgado por la
escuela de sobrevivencia tropical a
menudo llevaba a grupos de jóvenes
estadounidenses en expediciones dice que
quien lea el nombre inscrito sobre este
documento sepa que ese caminante de la
selva se enfrentó a los pantanos ya los
felinos de la zona del canal llamadas a
gris que sepa que por eso john mercier
es llamado alligator validador primera
clase
el mismo canal se convertía a veces en
un inmenso terreno de juego la carrera
de los cayucos fue un invento de un boy
scout townsend
la idea era perpetuar la tradición de
que cada uno hiciera su propia canoa o
cayuco y utilizarlo de cayucos
hoy en día esa carrera se sigue haciendo
todos los años pero el ambiente apacible
y los cayucos tallados a mano a partir
de un solo tronco de árbol fueron
reemplazados por canoas sofisticadas en
fibra de vidrio por patrocinadores y por
equipos que vienen del mundo entero con
el tiempo john se interesó por otras
ventajas que ofrecían la vida en la zona
porque esta es mi logia masónica
cuando entré en 1980 los francos masones
eran la organización más poderosa de la
zona algunos pensaban que si se volvían
masones iba a mejorar su estatus social
pero bueno como todos éramos masones al
final eso no hizo ninguna diferencia
pero los soneros no solo organizaban
divertidas aventuras en la selva
de hecho el territorio era ante todo una
inmensa base militar donde se hacían
entrenamientos cotidianos
arístide vivían afuera de la zona pero
el espacio utilizado por el ejército
estadounidense iba mucho más allá todos
los habitantes de su pueblo natal
crecieron con el sonido de la artillería
pero ya uno se va acostumbrando a ir a
los tiroteos la huella de las bombas que
se comentan el sonido de la metralleta
la nota estábamos estudiando en las
clases ya en hora de la tarde
venía lo que era la práctica más fuerte
venían los aviones de guerra las casas
temblaban como aquí voy hacia un temblor
un amigo de arístide pagó el precio
cuando era niño sufrió graves quemaduras
por todo el cuerpo mientras jugaban con
un obús que encontraron en un campo
porque fue tan fuerte que llegaron los
americanos lo recogieron y se lo
llevaron
le dieron atención médica eso de algo
que me ha quedado
para toda la vida
se estima que 33 mil hectáreas de panamá
podrían estar contaminadas con
explosivos algunas zonas también
sirvieron como terrenos de ensayo para
armas químicas entonces no se realizó
limpieza ellos dice que hicieron que
limpiaron pero
aún estaba aquí en esta selva cerca de
los pueblos muchos salen a cazar o a
pescar
un día que había ido a bañarse en un río
arístide también fue víctima de un
accidente me metí hacia el monte cuando
de repente yo sentí cargo media tocado
aquí así la barriga como que algo muy
aguanta un poco así yo escuché algo que
comenzó hace como
[Música]
arrate o escuchen la mala explosión
yo quedé que yo no escuchaba na
capello oído me hace ha sido escuchado a
los amigos que me estaban hablando
después de eso
tuvieron que operarle el tímpano hoy en
día no permite que sus nietos salgan a
caminar por la selva obús morteros
bombas durante una caminata es posible
encontrar varios todavía enteros pero la
falta de información sobre el tema
complica la gestión del peligro que yo
he conversado con varias personas y
ellos dicen que hay eso y no hay de eso
si los gringos limpiaron los gringos son
los mejores del mundo
lo americano yo no hacen eso ellos
mantienen una tienen esa mentalidad de
que es así que los americanos no no
tienen errores en cuestiones en
prácticas militares
[Música]
actualmente miroslava vive en clayton un
pueblo en la antigua zona una discreta
venganza pues antes cuando era niña solo
habría podido entrar con un permiso
especial
ahora mi raza del tambor de la alegría
el siglo 20 estadounidense impuesto a
los panameños dejó recuerdos
contrastantes
donde yo veo a bob dylan de
norteamericano chuck berry el
norteamericano el blues entonces no me
cuesta como señalar a los eeuu como el
mal vecino porque si políticamente
hicieron cosas equivocadas pero
culturalmente
creo que nos hemos ido mucho
quiero sembrar un maíz en la zona al fin
dueño de su destino los panameños ahora
enfrentan otros problemas la desigualdad
la corrupción la criminalidad bancaria
de escuchar la perdiz allá en la curva
lejana y encima de la montaña clavar la
señal a través de este puente que
franquea el canal se pasa de américa del
norte a américa del sur un lazo entre
dos continentes pero también una cultura
en las heridas del pasado
llegamos al final de boleto de vuelta a
panamá recuerde que si quiere ver este y
otros contenidos en español puede
visitar nuestra página web france24
puntocom hasta pronto